so hi everyone
thank you all so much for coming to this
talk with so many other good ones on at
the same time
i'm so happy we've all survived this
year
hope you're all enjoying strange loot so
far
it is really so rare
this year to for us to be able to share
space and mine space
so thank you all for making this happen
against all the odds
i'm melinda
and i'm here to talk about distributed
systems beyond request response
this is where i tweet about my partner's
lego
i work at egy where we're working on
making table sticks distributed systems
accessible to everyone we're also
working on trying to scale carbon
capture to get tons of carbon dioxide
per year by 2030 so
please talk to me afterward in person or
on slack if you're interested in that
um full disclosure i'm currently nursing
a brain injury from an unexpected fist
fight so please forgive me if i'm less
than articulate these couple days
and before this year i worked at vsco
and some other places
i had too fun too much fun drawing these
slides sorry there are no boats in this
presentation
so
if we're writing software that touches
the internet today there's no getting
around it we're building a distributed
system
some parts of our software are running
on mobile devices or in a web browser
maybe
some parts are running on the server
probably many parts are running on many
servers
and this is true even if we don't have
servers if we have multiple computing
devices and want them to share
underlying data in any way like say by
air dropping photos back and forth
us to have all of our photos available
on some device that's also a distributed
system
and so all of these parts are calling
each other over a network which may or
may not be working
might be running out of batteries might
have an exploited hard drive at any
point in time
but our software is expected to stay up
and running perfectly even though any of
its parts might be gone
that's difficult
internet-based software is inherently
distributed and distributed systems are
difficult to design build understand and
operate
but it is totally manageable if we
understand the constraints of this
context
and if we build the tools to make this
tractable if we build the ways of
reasoning to make this context feel
natural
when we build distributed systems we're
designing for three main concerns
first reliability
how to make sure that the system
continues to work correctly and
performantly
second maintainability how to make sure
that all the different people who are
going to work on our system over time
can understand and work on it
productively
and three scalability how to make sure
that we have reasonable ways to deal
with their systems as they grow
you guys should just yeah
but one overarching concern
with all of this is how we keep
complexity under control
when we start building something it can
be really simple delightful clean but
other projects get bigger they often
become complex and really difficult to
understand
and this complexity slows down everyone
who eventually needs to work on the
system we end up with tangled
dependencies hacks or special casing to
work around problems an explosion and
how much state we're keeping i'm sure
you've all seen these things
and one way that we try to manage
complexity that's been in vogue in our
industry in the last few years is by
breaking our software down into
independently deployable services
this does have many advantages services
can be worked on in parallel each
service can focus on a single domain we
have flexibility in how we solve larger
problems and so on
but these things are only true if we
decompose our software in the right way
and use patterns that fit our context
if we aren't careful we could end up
with software that's still tightly
coupled
but now also has an unreliable network
between each piece of business logic
and it's hard to deploy impossible to
debug
okay
so
why is this uh i posit
that one key property of our software
architecture
is the basic interaction style that we
choose like how our microservices
interact with each other
because we've broken our software down
into pieces now our system only works
when multiple services work together
and the default way that we typically do
interaction nowadays is request response
using synchronous network calls so in
this model we try to make requests to a
remote network service look like calling
functions in a programming language
within the same process
this seems really convenient at first
but seeing remote calls as function
calls is fundamentally flawed
because a network request is really
different from a local function call
a local function call is predictable and
either succeeds or fails
depending on parameters that are totally
under our control
but a network request is unpredictable
it could return successfully albeit much
more slowly than a function call
it could return successfully but
way more slowly than that
the network could be congested or the
remote service could be overloaded so it
might take 20 seconds or five minutes to
do the exact same thing
the request for response could get lost
due to a network problem or the remote
service could be unavailable or we could
hit a timeout without receiving a result
and we would have no idea what happened
if we don't receive a response from our
remote service we have no way of knowing
whether the request got through or not
maybe the requests are actually getting
through for example and only the
responses are getting lost so it's
probably not safe for us to retry it
unless we've built in a mechanism for
deduplication this is a really rough
environment to be in really different
from running on a single computer
and because of this our distributed
systems
uh our distributive software
that interacts using request response
can be incredibly hard to reason about
let's imagine that unlike this slide we
have on the order of a hundred or a
thousand services communicating with
each other in this point-to-point way
imagine how many different
point-to-point connections that is
and this is what a large
distributed service architecture can
look like this is um a essential
streaming service and sponsor netflix's
architecture circa 2015 the series of
lions on the right from a re-invent talk
showing a network of services and their
synchronous runtime dependencies on
other services some people refer to this
representation as a death star diagram
we can see that as the number of
services grows over time the number of
synchronous interactions grows with them
somewhere between linearly and
quadratically
and if we zoom into one service this was
the call graph for a single netflix
service from the same talk sorry to keep
talking about this one example from 2015
i just had nice diagrams
this was the list of list of movies
service and these were all the services
that i had to talk to in order to return
a response we can see that this one
service depends on many other ones and
that any of these end dependencies being
down if they're critical to the service
can cause availability issues for our
one service
and apart from just availability we have
latency which grows with the depth of
the dependency graph we probably need to
coordinate read times between when each
of these is querying a data store and we
are likely just going to find it
extremely difficult to reason about the
state of the system at any point in time
there's a lot going on
so much so that the only reasonable
approach is often
not to reason about this dependency
graph at all and just work
just work to make every dependency
significantly more available than
necessary um as noted in this paper a
service can't be more available than the
intersection of all of its critical
dependencies so for example if we want
our service to offer 99.99
availability we can just make our
critical dependencies much more than
99.99 available
and this approach is discussed in depth
in this paper from engineers at google
that that's one option or we could wait
and see how the system performs in
practice and diagnose issues as they
arise which in practice is very fun like
a murder mystery
it's fun because it entails digging
through tons of complexity sometimes
while a pager is going off next to me
but it's let's say sub-optimal
we can also do things to protect our
response
our request response services like say
let's make automatic request retries
when we don't get a response back with
back pressure we can add caches in
between clients and servers we can have
multiple redundant copies of services
that can take requests when only one
copy is broken with readiness and
liveness checks that route to the right
ones i should stop moving my hands
dynamic service discovery load balancing
circuit breaking
surface meshes like lingard d and istio
to make this more transparent to the
user
just interesting these are all standard
patterns for software that runs on the
internet the software software that runs
in the cloud
but these are standard patterns
which we take for granted because
trusting request response to work
in a hostile environment like the cloud
is inherently risky
and so much of the mind share in the
microservices landscape the libraries
the tooling the documentation blog posts
the books diagrams
it assumes this model of services
calling each other synchronously
and i think it's just a little
unfortunate that we so often conflate
the core values and goals of
microservices with a specific model
request response for their
implementation this is also a hostile
environment
but what if
instead of patching these solutions for
resilience on top of request response we
could change the problem to a simpler
one by just not binding our services
together with synchronous ties
i see this as analogous to the divide
between imperative and functional
programming the request response model
of service communication matches our
sequential imperative programming model
of making in-place state changes on a
single computer and we've seen how that
isn't perfectly suited for a distributed
environment
functional programming in contrast
describes behavior in terms of the
immutable input and output values of
pure functions not in terms of mutating
objects in place
if we model the way our services
communicate zooming way out more
functionally
what would our systems look like
and we've seen in the past few years how
thinking about things in a more
functional way helps in other parts of
the stack on the web we've had reactive
frameworks like react and redux and vue
and elm which you'll hear about here as
well before that
that almost everyone has shifted to
after seeing how they can simplify
things on mobile the newest generation
of ui frameworks on both ios and android
is functional and reactive and we've had
libraries for reactivity and business
logic for a long time
on the infrastructure side we've really
seen how declarative apis like
kubernetes infrastructure as code tools
like terraform
and deployment via git make things much
easier to reason about
but i think we're still early in
adopting this in backend application
development
what would it look like if we extended
this functional programming analogy to a
microservices architecture
this is the idea behind event driven
architecture
like functional programming sorry event
driven architecture lets us know
consistently the state of the system as
long as we know its input events
so there are lots of different different
definitions of the details of what can
be called an event-driven system
but the common piece is that the thing
that triggers code execution in an
event-driven system doesn't wait for any
response it just sends it and then
forgets about it so in this diagram on
the left you can see a request and
response when a request is received the
receiving server has to return some
kind of response to the client
so that means both the client and the
server have to be alive healthy and
focusing on each other in order for this
to work
on the other hand on the right there's
an event-driven service the service that
consumes the event still does something
with it yes
but it doesn't have to send any response
to the thing that originally created the
event that triggered it only this one
service has to be alive for this code to
be run it doesn't depend on other
services being there it's not coupled to
the thing that produced the event it
doesn't have to know about the producer
at all
in an event driven service we're
centering the transformation
functional ish not the interaction in a
stateful way
and the way that this usually looks in
practice is that we use a message broker
or distributed log to store these events
these days this is usually a distributed
a partition distributed log like kafka
or kinesis or something similar
events can
be split into different streams called
topics which then get partitioned across
a horizontally scalable cluster each of
our services can then consume from one
or more topics produced from one or more
topics or do both or neither
and when we compose many of these
event-driven services together
and have them respond to inputs from the
outside world this makes up a reactive a
whole reactive system
but so
moving to an event-driven more
functional and data-centric model
is a really different way of having
programs interact with each other and if
we're going to make this change we'd
better have some really good reasons
the biggest reason i think
for making this change is the decoupling
and easy composability the modularity
that this gives us
by getting rid of these point-to-point
synchronous flows our system can become
much simpler instead of having having
the work to add things will scale
quadratically
ish like this
because every new thing has to be hooked
up to every existing thing
it becomes a much simpler task to plug
new services in or change services that
are already there
we can break these long chains of
blocking commands where one piece being
down at any given time means all of
these are unavailable
and again we do this by using a
distributed log a partitioned append
only log that all producers and
consumers use as a central pipeline that
provides strong ordering semantics and
durability guarantees
and zooming out to a whole organization
these design principles let us build
composable systems at a really large
scale in a large orb different teams can
independently design and build services
that consume from topics and produce to
new topics
since a topic can have any number of
independent consumers no coordination is
required to set up a new consumer and
consumers can be displayed deployed at
will or built with different
technologies via different languages or
libraries or different data stores even
each team just focuses on making their
particular part of the system do its job
well
so as a real life example this is how
this worked at visco where i worked
before this year
vsco is a photo and video sharing
consumer platform where users have their
own profile and can follow each other
and so on a social network
what happens if a user follows another
user in the app
well the first thing that happens
is that they hit a synchronous follow
service
which then tries to get that information
about the follow into the distributed
log kafka as soon as possible and once
it's there it can be used for many
things it gets consumed by this feed
found out worker so that the follower
can get the follow ease posts injected
in their feed it gets consumed by the
push notification pipeline so the
follower we can see that you've gotten a
new follower and so on each of these
downstream services has either one or
several defined input message types and
are defined output message type or types
and the key is that we can keep on
plugging more consumers we could add
monitoring so we can see if the rate of
follows gives the way down and business
metrics might be affected by some change
in our app design or something like that
or if it goes way up in case something
weird is going on we could add an abuse
prevention mechanism to see if something
weird is going on we could add analytics
in case we need to report to wall street
or something and so on
all of these systems can be developed
independently and connected and composed
in a way that is and feels
robust and just as functional languages
let us divide a large problem into
sub-problems and sub-sub-problems then
combine these
uh then combine these problem solutions
together to solve the original problems
and other ones
using event driven services lets us glue
granular functions together in flexible
ways we can localize knowledge about the
details of each computation in analogy
to higher order functions
and we can perform a computation exactly
and only as needed
because an event is created only when
something changes which is kind of
analogous to lazy evaluation
in contrast in our request response
system we might need to pull a service
dependency and have it perform a query
say a thousand or a million times in
order to receive a single change
a side benefit of this is that we get
asynchronous flows for free
so often there are computations that
even in the request response system we
would want to happen outside the user
user path or even more infrequently like
say an hourly or daily batch job
it used to be that we need to do a bunch
of orchestration to set up best jobs
with say airflow or luigi or something
like that but if we handle the real-time
case with events then our offline jobs
are just like any other consumer and
they work by default
and this functional composition makes
things easier to debug and trace as well
so
by the definition of event driven
service that we've made we have a
central immutable and saved journal of
every interaction and its inputs and
outputs so we can go back and see
exactly where something failed to get
this with request response we'd have to
invest lots of time and energy in a full
distributed tracing system and even then
it's really hard to see where latencies
might be hidden
another reason that event driven systems
are helpful is that in many ways they
can provide scale by default and make
some of the patterns that we use for
resilience and request response service
architecture is unnecessary
so
for example as we saw earlier
the distributed log really can act as a
buffer if the recipient is unavailable
or overloaded it will automatically
redeliver messages to a processes crash
it can prevent messages from being lost
and so this makes something like retries
with back pressure and health checks
less necessary
the log prevents the sender from needing
to know the ip address and port number
of the recipient which is particularly
useful in say a cloud environment where
servers go up and down all the time
and so it makes complex service
discovery and load balancing much less
necessary
office fifth okay uh if we're running an
application today we are very likely to
want to use several different data
storage systems or databases to serve
different use cases
uh there's no single
fits one-size-fits-all database that's
able to fit all the different access
patterns efficiently this is sometimes
called polyglot persistence
so for example we might need users to
perform a keyword search on a data set
and so we'll need a full text search
index service like elasticsearch
uh we might need a specialized database
like a scientific or graph database to
do specialized data structure traversal
say or filters we might have a data
warehouse for business analytics where
we need a really different storage
layout like say
a column oriented storage engine
we have all these things when new data
gets written how do we make sure that it
ends up in all the right places
we could write to all the databases from
synchronous microservices dual reds
triple quadruple quintuple rights but
we've seen how that is fragile
and it's impossible to make dual rights
consistent without distributed
transactions and you can read about all
of this in detail in this paper from
martin klepman and collaborators
a more provably correct way of doing
this though is with event driven systems
there are two main patterns that i've
tried using that we can choose from to
do this in an event-driven way
first we could do this with database
change capture which is a database first
approach or we could do this with event
sourcing which is an event first
approach
the database change capture pattern is
the one that i've used more often in
practice
and it's really based on an old idea
the idea is that we let applications
subscribe to a stream of everything
that's written to a database inserts
updates deletes and then we can use that
feed to do the things listed earlier we
can update search indices we can
invalidate caches we can create
snapshots so on so forth there are open
source libraries that
help get this feed of every database
change for different databases into a
distributed broker like kafka where
consumers can access it for example the
most well known is probably dibsium
which uses kafkaconnect and databases
are increasingly started starting to
support these change streams as a first
party interface
at visco because we started doing this
back in 2016 before there were common
tools for this we wrote our own go
service called audubon to get this
database change feed into kafka by
tilling the my sql binary log and a
mongodb blog directly
and we use something similar for our
relational databases at iggy
but going back to the follows use case
for social network
the way that the event gets into the
distributed log in the first place
with database change capture is
that the follow service writes to
an online transactional database say
something like mysql or mongodb
then our database change capture service
writes every change in that database to
the distributed log where then any
number of consumers can do whatever they
want with it
sidebar this ends up being a really nice
way to migrate off of a monolith we can
let the monolith keep doing the initial
database right suck those rights into
our event store with database change
capture and then pull out all the reads
and extra stuff that the model it does
for every right into composable workers
reading off of the event store
and this helps us fix one of the most
common pitfalls in microservice
architecture where we have we where we
do have a bunch of independently
deployable services but they all share a
single database
where this kind of broad shared contract
really makes it hard to figure out what
effects any changes might have and
negates the advantages of having a
microservices architecture we would much
rather not have our data be so coupled
but it's hard to unbundle it at that
point
database change capture can make it much
easier
we can also save even richer data with
event driven systems if we want to
so
writing data directly to the log can
produce better quality data than if we
just update a database for example if
someone adds an item to their shopping
cart and then removes it again we are
buying furniture here
those add and delete actions do have
informational value and if we lose that
information from the database when a
customer removes an item from the cart
we've just thrown away information that
might have been used useful for
analytics or recommenders
or any other systems
and this approach where we write events
first and directly to the distributed
log
is usually given the name event sourcing
which comes originally from the domain
driven design community
so like database change capture event
sourcing involves saving all the changes
to the application state as a log of
change events but instead of letting one
part of the application use the database
in a mutable way and update and delete
records
as it likes in event sourcing our
application logic is explicitly built on
the basis of immutable events
and that event store is purely append
only usually updates or deletes are
discouraged or prohibited and then if we
want to get a copy of our current
working tree we'd aggregate over all the
diffs over time
so in a fully event source system the
current state is derived
both this and the mutable version are
valid approaches but they come with
slightly different trade-offs in
practice
regardless of which one we use the
important thing is to save facts as
they're observed in an event log
in practice i haven't personally used
this pattern as much as the database
first change capture approach because
the combination of fast
transaction protected state updates and
totally ordered downstream effects has
been hard to beat
but the event searching approach is just
as valid if we have different design
constraints and probably more
theoretically beautiful
and one thing that falls out of all of
these other reasons
is that this makes integrating machine
learned logic very very straightforward
so nowadays we often want to plug
machine learnable programs into
different parts of our software where we
can get better results than by hand
coding some program and this will be
increasingly true in the future
let's say
that we want to decide on the fly
whether our request is from a legitimate
actor
or
i don't know send a user through a
different onboarding flow depending on
how they behave or
tune a database indexes new data of
different shapes comes in whatever the
ml
application is inserting ml like this
will really not be tractable if we do
this in a point-to-point request
response way many of us have probably
been asked to insert a machine learning
inference step into an existing system
and had to build a ton of hacky infra
around it to get it to work
which is frustrating and not scalable
our software just becomes totally
incomprehensible
but if we've already switched to using
an event driven system we have plugable
data integration points already there
for us and adding ml is just adding
another consumer or producer
and last and this is more speculative
but
is it but where i hope we can take this
one day is can we thread this all the
way through to the clients
right now clients usually have to pull
for changes to find out when something
they've loaded has changed so the
fastest that we can possibly get an
update is the polling interval of the
clients which is
usually probably too long to work for
any low latency use cases
but
if we can thread event driven
architecture end to end which we almost
have the right tooling for um then we
can push these event driven
notifications all the way through the
stack to the browser or the mobile app
or the forklift or the sale drone or
whatever if we do that
then we won't
ever have to see still data anymore and
we won't need to pull every second
with all of that said there are some
things to watch out for when you're
building your event driven systems
one key decision is how you want to
structure your event data since the
events are now our implant output
interface the way that our request and
response types were our interface where
our interface in a request response
system
so our systems do and well change over
time as features are added and changed
inevitably
and we'll need to handle backward and
forward compatibility in order to make
sure we can update to newer versions
without breaking our applications
um just like with request response we'll
likely want to use a schema language
with evolvability rules and this is my
biased compiler checking of constraints
like protocol buffers avro or thrift
something like this
at agi we use protocol buffers plus a
custom code gen plug-in that lets us
define input and or output types for
each of our event-driven services
these types generate bindings that then
handle the standard worker functionality
check constraints let us write tests et
cetera et cetera kind of like grpc but
for asynchronous services instead of
synchronous ones
which if there's any interest in we can
throw on github
i would really just recommend using some
typed data serialization system here
where we can ensure safe schema
evolution in a developer friendly way
and not trying to manage these changes
on top of json or xml or something like
that
another piece is concurrency management
so say we now have distributed data
management how do we make sure that we
read all of the implications of our
rights
what the event driven service approach
guarantees us
is that every event will eventually be
processed by every consumer even if
there are crashes but there's no
guarantee about the upper bound
until uh of time until an event is
processed which means that our data
stores will eventually con converge on a
consistent state but they might be
inconsistent when they're read at one
point in time request response doesn't
exactly solve this problem either but
it's much more obvious when we're using
an event-based approach and we have to
design explicitly for this eventual
consistency
in our event-based systems also we
depend heavily on this distributed log
to provide
strong semantics around total ordering
distributed logs do this really well but
we have to be careful about how we
structure and partition our logs in
order to scale without losing ordering
in particular
with a distributed log with a
distributed partition log there's a
trade-off between using a single
partition for a topic which limits the
total scalability of the system sorry
but guarantees total ordering within the
topic
between that and breaking the topic into
independent partitions by entity which
guarantees ordering within an entity's
events but not ordering between them
between entities and if we know that our
data model is more complex and can be
handled with a single partition and key
we also can handle interactions between
partitions by breaking them down into
multiple event processing stages
and related to that
uh when we're building event driven
systems we do have to consider the
notion of identity of our end
of the identity of our entities very
carefully
all of our messages need to be uniquely
identified in order to say
detect duplicates implement optimistic
concurrency control manage deletes and
so on
in general the event driven approach
does require more upfront design but
gives us this payoff of lower cognitive
load and simpler changes in the future
the way of the future that
that's at least in my experience
and just like in request response
systems privacy and data deletability
are critical given gdpr ccpa and other
privacy regulations and also just doing
right by our users
when we delete a single piece of data we
want to make sure that we want that we
can delete all the pieces of data
derived from it which might now be in
many data stores event driven processing
can make it easier to perform this
deletion because all it's all just
consumers and consumers
but it might also make it more likely
that we have more data to delete
and with all of these decisions we need
to make sure that we don't conflate the
underlying fundamentals
with the tools that we choose is not
about kubernetes or kafka tools and
frameworks change quickly but the
fundamentals stay
mostly ish the same
the biggest gotcha with this though
although it's becoming less and less
true
is the event-driven interactions are not
the norm yet and so there are just fewer
libraries and tools and blog posts and
example repos about this than about
request response architecture
but many things that we use and
appreciate today weren't the default a
few years ago either and we've seen now
how they've made our lives easier
now i didn't have time to show a demo of
this here
but i really wanted to so i put one up
at this link there's code and a short
video almost lightly length it's a full
stack web and back-end breakfast
delivery service it doesn't actually
deliver you breakfast sorry with two
different architectures
first request response microservices
then event driven microservices
check it out if you don't already have
an event driven system and you want to
try to run one or just see one running
or if you're just interested in
breakfast
and if you're interested in lunch i'll
let you go now thank you so much for
your time
[Applause]
[Music]
you